♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING,
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT," BETO O'ROURKE'S
CAMPAIGN RETURN AMERICA TO 1995
IS OFF TO A SURPRISINGLY ROUGH
START TONIGHT.
INSTEAD OF TELLING US MORE ABOUT
THE SKATE FORWARD TRICKS AND
THOUGH WE'D HOOK UPS, O'ROURKE
IS APOLOGIZING FOR HIS SKIN
COLOR, TRULY.
WE HAVE MORE THAN THAT IN JUST
AHEAD.
BUT THE MUELLER REPORT COMING
ANY DAY NOW.
WE DON'T REALLY KNOW THAT IT IS
COMING ANY DAY NOW, BUT
EVERYBODY IN WASHINGTON IS
SAYING THAT.
BUT THERE ARE INDICATIONS THAT
IT MIGHT BE.
MATTHEW WHITAKER FOR ONE HAS
SAID THAT IT IS PRETTY MUCH
WRAPPED UP.
IN ANY CASE, ALL OF THIS WILL
END AT SOME POINT.
AND WHEN IT DOES, IT WILL BE
CHAOS IN THE NEWS BUSINESS.
EVERY INTERESTED PARTY WILL SPIN
IT TO THEIR OWN END.
BEFORE THAT HAPPENS, LET'S PAUSE
TO PUT IT IN PERSPECTIVE AND
REMEMBER HOW THE RUSSIA-HOAX
BEGAN IN THE FIRST PLACE.
THROUGHOUT THE 2016 PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN, HILLARY CLINTON AND
HER SURROGATES IN THE MEDIA
ATTACKED DONALD TRUMP FOR HIS
ROLE IN PUSHING THE BIRTHER
STORY.
THEY ARGUED THAT IT WAS DUMB TO
THINK THAT BARACK OBAMA WAS BORN
IN KENYA AND IT HURT AMERICA.
IT DELEGITIMIZED HIM AS A LEADER
BY CASTING HIM AS AN
ILLEGITIMATE PRESIDENT.
THOSE ARE FAIR POINTS.
IF YOU CANNOT PROVE SOMETHING IS
TRUE, YOU SHOULD NOT CLAIM THAT
IT IS.
IF YOU DO NOT LIKE A PRESIDENT'S
POLICIES, ARGUE AGAINST THEM.
OFFER A BETTER ALTERNATIVE.
DO NOT CLAIM THAT HE ISN'T
REALLY THE PRESIDENT.
THAT DOES NOT HELP THE COUNTRY.
SOMEHOW DEMOCRATS LEARN THE
OPPOSITE LESSON.
FOR THREE YEARS THEY PUSH THEIR
OWN FORMER HARMFUL CONSPIRACY,
THE THEORY OF RUSSIA COLLUSION.
THIS WAS ALL INVENTED BY THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN FOR SHORT-TERM
POLITICAL GAIN DURING THE RACE.
SHOWING HOW FUSION GPS WORKING
ON BEHALF OF THE CLINTONS WORK
TO PUBLICIZE THE STEELE DOSSIER.
IT WAS NOTHING MORE THAN GOSSIP,
NO RESPECTED NEWS AGENCY WOULD
PUBLISH IT.
INSTEAD IT PITCH THE LIES --
GLENN SIMPSON MET WITH BRUCE OR
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
CHRISTOPHER STEELE MET WITH
JOHN BOEHNER AT THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
AND HE SPREAD THE INFORMATION TO
HIS COLLEAGUES.
AND PRESIDENT OBAMA AND JIM
COMEY WERE BRIEFED ON THE
DOSSIER.
NEVER HAS OPPOSITION RESEARCH
AND A PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN
REACHED HIGHER LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT.
MEANWHILE, THE PRESS USED THIS
FACT AS A PRIESTESS FOR
PUBLISHING THE DOSSIER.
WE CANNOT PROVE THAT IT IS TRUE,
BUT PEOPLE ARE TALKING ABOUT IT,
SO IT IS NEWS.
BUZZFEED ADMITTED THAT THAT WAS
THE THINKING ON THE SHOW.
THIS DOCUMENT TO IS BEING FOUGHT
OVER AND EVERYBODY EXCEPT THE
PUBLIC HAS SEEN, WE HAVE SEEN.
AND WE DO NOT HAVE ANY SPECIAL
POWERS, BUT AT WHAT POINT DOES
THE AUDIENCE SAY, WE CAN SEE
THIS TOO AND DEAL WITH THE FACT
THAT IT IS OKAY LABELED AS
UNVERIFIED AND CLEARLY LABELED
AS SOMETHING'S THAT ARE NOT TRU
TRUE.
>> Tucker: SO YOU'RE SAYING
BECAUSE FAMOUS PEOPLE ARE
GOSSIPING ABOUT IT AND
BECAUSE --
>> THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, THE
PRESIDENT-ELECT.
THE GARDEN-VARIETY FAMOUS
PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: AND LET ME KNOW --
>> THE DOCUMENT IS A PUBLIC
DOCUMENT SUBJECT TO THE FREEDOM
OF INFORMATION LAW.
>> Tucker: IT IS GOSSIP
BECAUSE IT IS UNVERIFIED, THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT YOU DID
AND WHAT HE DID IS HE REPORTED
THAT IT WAS UNTRUE AS YOU SAID
NOT TRUE.
>> Tucker: NOT GOSSIP OFFICIAL
BRIEFING, A PLOY TO THE
POLITICAL OPPONENT.
EVERYBODY KNEW THAT.
AND IN FACT IN THE YEAR SINCE NO
EVIDENCE HAVE US EMERGED TO
VERIFY THE MAIN CLAIMS.
IT WAS FAKE THEN, IT IS FAKE
NOW.
BUT IT STILL CAUSED AN AWFUL LOT
OF DAMAGE.
THE FRAUDULENT DOSSIER WAS USED
TO JUSTIFY THE GROTESQUE CIVIL
RIGHTS VIOLATIONS PERPETRATED ON
CARTER PAGE.
AND JUSTIFIED MULTIPLE
CONGRESSIONAL INVESTIGATIONS
WHICH GROUND GOVERNMENT TO A
HALT AND HELP DESTROY A
RELATIONSHIP WITH RUSSIA THAT
DID NOT NEED TO HAPPEN, BUT IT
DID THINGS TO THE HOAX.
AND THE DOSSIER JUSTIFIED
HUNDREDS IF NOT THOUSANDS OF
TOTALLY IRRESPONSIBLE REMARKS BY
POLITICIANS AND JOURNALISTS.
YOU MAY REMEMBER SOME OF THEM.
TED LIEU SAID THAT THERE WAS A
"CLOUD OF TREASON" OVER THE
WHITE HOUSE.
CALLING TRUMP A RUSSIA AGENT
HIDING IN PLAIN SIGHT.
EVEN NANCY PELOSI WHO IS
SUPPOSED TO BE RESPONSIBLE AND
SHOULD KNOW BETTER SAID IT WAS
CERTAIN THAT RUSSIA WAS
BLACKMAILING THE PRESIDENT.
ALL OF THESE WERE LIES.
NOBODY HAS APOLOGIZE FOR THEM.
WHEN THE MUELLER REPORT DOES
DROP, HOW WILL THEY EXPLAIN TO
THEIR FOLLOWERS, THE NPR
LISTENERS, THE PEOPLE WHO READ
THE NEW YORKER, THE ENTIRE
AUDIENCE AT CNN WHY THERE IS NO
PROOF OF COLLUSION IN THE
DOCUMENT?
ACCORDING TO ONE POLL, 67% OF
DEMOCRATS BELIEVE THAT IT IS
PROBABLY OR DEFINITELY TRUE THAT
RUSSIA TAMPERED WITH VOTE
TALLIES TO HELP TRUMP WIN.
IN WASHINGTON PEOPLE KNOW THAT
THAT IS LUDICROUS.
EVERYBODY HERE UNDERSTANDS THE
GAME.
BUT OUT THERE PEOPLE REALLY
BELIEVE THIS STUFF.
NANCY PELOSI AND SCHIFF AND
SWALLOWED TOLD THEM THAT IT WAS
TRUE.